but it's about one-third about one-third
of america's report they don't wear a
mask at all
as i've said in the last two years
please wear a mask
if you're in a you know i think it's
part of your patriotic duty it's not
that
comfortable it's a pain in the neck
but
i've taken every action i can as
president to require people to wear
masks in federal buildings and on
airplanes and trains because their
internet they cross state lines
we also have helped make sure that high
quality masks are widely available in
ample supply at affordable prices sold
online and in stores
but i know that for some americans the
mask is not always affordable or
convenient to get so
next week we'll announce
we'll announce how
we are making high quality masks
available to american people the
american people for free
i you know i know we all wish that we
could finally be done with wearing masks
i get it
but there is a really important tool
to stop the spread especially of a
highly transmittable omicron variant
so please please wear the mask
i'm directing my team to procure an
additional half a bill additional 500
million more tests to distribute for
free
that made a billion tests in total
to meet future demand
and we'll continue to work with the
retailers and online re and on online
retailers
uh to increase availability
and for those who want an immediate test
we continue to add fema testing sites
so that there are more than
more free in-person testing sites
for those of you with insurance
you can get reimbursed for eight tests a
month
for those without insurance we have over
20 000
free testing sites all around the
country
third thing
today we'll discuss our hospital
response efforts
just thanks to this thing
just since thanksgiving
over 800 military and other federal
emergency personnel have been deployed
to 24 states tribes and territories
including over 350 military doctors
nurses and medics helping staff the
hospitals are in short supply
this is on top of more than 14 000
national guard members that are active
activated in 49 states
these deployments in my direction and
thanks to the american rescue plan are
fully paid for by the federal government
we've shipped over 5.5 million pieces of
protect personal protective equipment
gloves gowns masks to protect front
aligned healthcare workers
we're shipping more treatments of covet
19 which includes antiviral pills
then at any point during this pandemic
in addition i've directed fema to work
with every state territory in the
district of columbia to make sure they
have enough hospital bed capacity
today i'm announcing our next deployment
of six additional federal medical teams
a total of more than 120 military
medical personnel
to six hard-hit states
michigan new york
new jersey ohio rhode island
and let me close with this
it's been a long road
but what's clear
as we get through this when everybody
does their part
no matter where you live
no matter your political party we've got
to fight this together